hey folks please enjoy this clip from
our show which you can find every single
day at 400 p.m. Eastern exclusively on
Rumble we've been doing the best shows
we've ever done completely free of
censorship and on a platform that
actually supports us you can also
support us on locals where you can
access a ton of exclusive content movie
riffs as well as an archive of over a
thousand full episodes going back as far
as 7 years we've also teamed up with
merch engine to bring you a new lineup
of really awesome quality shirts hoodies
and now even hats so come check out our
untethered uncensored show on Rumble
every single weekday at 400 p.m. Eastern
you stupid
idiots yes I know I'm very excited for
we're about to
play very very
excited
no no no no no no no no no no you didn't
even know what it is why are you saying
yeah I do yeah I
do yeah I knew it
why are you smoking weed why are you
trying to take drugs to F to F why is
I'm do I'm furiously doing the same
thing okay you know what just because
you guys can't I'm packing my dab thing
just because you guys can't I'm packing
my my my dab I hate this just because
you guys don't understand what good oh
someone come come on there it is just
still want a dare shirt no huh no this
says facts they don't care about your
feelings so the thing that nobody all
right can we start talking facts about
Israel not those kind of facts what
about tunnels see M there's the truth
and the
truth
um he's Tom McDonald people are being
like dude you're a [__] sellout
people like oh I he was like oh I a
sellout I'm like
bro I tweeted out man it's it's it's a
good T good thing Tom McDonald stayed
100% independent or he would have been
taken advantage of by a Jewish
producer uh let's see here this song is
called
facts they call me off are controversial
there only two genders boys and girls
they can't cancel my message cuz I'm the
biggest independer in theak world huh
what do you think so far where are we at
but you're not though where we
at but you're I'm racist yeah right I'm
not ashamed because I'm white if every
Caucasian a bigot I guess every muslim's
a terrorist
is so every song is the same yes yes the
guy has hog tattooed in his mouth yeah
so you know where to put it makes
sense Democrats are the real
racist well it's like has always said
bro it's just Facebook meme rap it's
what it is it's it's Facebook it's it's
it's Boomer Facebook Boomer core it's
stuff your aunt shares to her timeline
yeah I like you know also the remember
when when Tom McDonald little Rolling
Stone the little Rolling Stone piece cuz
you know he's so independent and so out
there that he does r the Rolling Stone
piece where he called kle R house a
murderer well yeah he said KY rhouse was
out there look took somebody's life and
we shouldn't be championing him
mhm Bas right Bas in red pill yeah he
murdered a pedophile sir yeah this
Boomer core by the way that's the name
this called Boomer core Boomer core I
like it Boomer
core go ahead and put that out there
that way like [__] I don't know
[__] who's quarter Ringle steal it or
somebody
[Music]
yeah you won't turn your daughters into
the hose says says the man that if he
showed up at anybody's house and said
I'm here to take out your daughter the
father would slam the door in their
[__] face you're a wigger you're
stupid
[Music]
wigger yeah you're so
edgy we're all scared of you you can
crying you can scream you can ride in
the street you defunded the police now
there's no one to
you
I you do you ask yourself ask myself
what would Ben
do we're doomed I asked myself what
would Ben do we're doomed Michelle
Obama's gonna be our president yeah or
Gavin
Newsome it's not going to be Gavin this
time no it'll be a girl you think it's
going to be Michelle Obama okay
let's just keep it real f it how you
feel man if you want my PRS I'm the man
I'm the man who don't get ready here we
go here we go you ready oh no here it
comes here it comes the moment we've all
been waiting for no no no you've been
waiting for it the moment we've all been
waiting for clamoring
for are you ready I'm going to go get my
gun are you ready no I guess look at the
stats I've got the my money likez my
pockets are oh
no I thought they were just going to use
samples oh no no he R he wrote a well he
had a verse written for him he waps
mer oh no merch
broke I hope I hope Michelle Obama wins
I hope America dies it deserves it the
experiment failed
I'm not kidding I want this country to
die here we go here we go here we go oh
wait sorry we got to take The Showdown
now I just threatened the whole country
hey do me a favor virgy message Jesse
Kelly let Jesse Kelly know thanks
[__] we had to take our Showdown
because of
you you want
you want to hear that line again did you
hear that line though no no have to list
don't do this please don't no no I am I
aming this we not going to keep going
back and words you have to listen to the
words I listened the first time no but I
don't think so because you I'm taking my
headphones it's a yamaka homie No Cap No
Cap yamaka No Cap yam No
Cap come on
merch Merch this is not very Cash Money
of you I'm not coming back it's not cash
money of you at all no more going back
we just played through one time like you
know who wouldn't do this cuz he's so
nice Dave landow y oh my God he actually
left oh no oh my internet my internet
farted and I was like please please go
that couldn't have been a better timed I
was like please actually go out this
time it's your boy B
[Music]
that was me that was me violently
ripping my ethernet cord out of my
computer I think I damaged the
port my money like Liz my pockets are
fat homie I'm epic don't be a WAP dog
it's a yomie no cap look at the graphs
look at my charts you're blowing money
on strippers and cards you going into
prison I'm on television dogs no one
knows who you are keep hating on me on
the internet my com
I comp interest I make racks off
compound interest like if I make that
joke if I were to make that joke you
would call me anti-semitic yeah and
you'd be
right I can't I can't do this well I
didn't go back this time I didn't go
back this time I really did on me on the
internet my com section woke and I make
racks off compound interest yall live
with your parents Nikki take some notes
I just did this for fun all my people
download this let's get a billboard
number one this ain't oh by the way
they're bragging right now the number
one rap song yeah yeah I know they they
haven't stopped on iTunes they haven't
stopped they haven't stopped on iTunes
who the [__] uses iTunes yes that's
literally yeah it's it's it's the same
thing it's the same algorithm Tim P
manipulated who the [__] has an
iPod hey hey he doesn't care if he
offends you
the only thing offensive about this is
that the [__] Can't Rap anything
other than ABAB ab ab ab king of all
pixels can we get a meet you at The
Omelette bar shirt I like that Tom Rose
Mercedes no I'm not gay hence I'm not uh
liking somebody who again has the body
of a 12-year-old boy he's doubling down
on the Gwen Stefani ha hey watp live
tell Carl we're not coming to the show
unless there's an omelet station and
Gwen Stefani's there
yes uh dark comedy everyone just vote uh
Democrats liberal at this point we
should we should be able to just skip
the uh conscription and go straight to
the
nukes hey can somebody make a uh an AI
picture of Taylor Swift eating at the
omelet station that would be great can
somebody to do a t you can't do Taylor
Swift anywhere right now I guarantee you
dude Bing AI will not let dude not only
will Bing AI not let you do Taylor Swift
you also can't do Kansas City Chief's
jerseys there's so many things you can't
do right now
number one this ain't R this ain't money
cars and clothes we ain't selling drugs
we ain't going to overdose we
ain't I wish you would
overdose he will don't worry give let
him cook can you overdose on
hubris Keith overman's still
alive they're
[Laughter]
afraid I don't if
I
I was play to
say you can cry you can scream you can
ride in the street you
def we're in Louis Vuitton glasses I am
a [__] nobody likes and I'm afraid
blacks are going to steal my
[Laughter]
bike I don't know be
Jewish so just just a double this
judeo-christian rap
song um they're taking the old what
would Jesus do and switching it to what
would Ben
do bro I swear to
God I swear to God I'm not kidding you
I'm I'm more than okay now with with
this whole thing going over a
cliff well it's going to buddy yeah
don't worry about it it's coming yeah
[__] is it because you don't is it
because you don't normally like rap
music yeah no I do actually like rap
music well let's see the comments let's
see what they have to say normally I
don't like rap music this is epic but
there's gonna be a lot of this is epic
moreb bin Shapiro Tom McDonald
please um right now I I have a feeling
that they delete comments ments you know
you
think who would have ever guessed they
have to there's too much positivity in
his comment section my money like fizzo
lizo my pockets are fat and they're
they're they're freaking out like that's
one of the best lines that was ever
written that's a terrible that's not
even that line in and of itself didn't
even
rhyme okay we got a we got a good one we
got a good line you
ready I'm on I'm a I'm a 103y old black
male on my deathbed and I don't normally
Listen to Hip Hop thing but this Thomas
I can get behind keep making this good
music son fire Emoji sir
die you deserve you deserve that has to
be a troll that has to be a troll that
has to be a troll a 103y old black man I
mean that happens sometimes on
YouTube well what else you going to do
in the
hospital die or the clinic uh awesome
video as always I love Ben F okay you
know what let's look you know what let's
switch I hate this I want this country
to end let's switch it to newest first
I'm not voting for Trump by the way I
don't give a [__] I don't care what he
does between now and then I'm not I I am
voting 100% for
acceleration this is [__] cringe he
made I'm not kidding I'm voting
Democrats this time I'm done I am
done overuse talking points the song is
another good
comment this was so
good Ben spitting bars it's women by the
way the people that like that like um
Tom McDonald are women yeah women are
terrible they have bad taste in
everything yeah they do women need to be
told how to live
well that's because all the guys they
dated are
narcissist so did you think of that guy
that's ever offered me constructive
criticism was a narcissist M correct un
unironically [__] is a better
song yeah yeah what of course it is yeah
it had Megan the stallion on it
yeah